oh please thank you very much hey
everybody
wow it is uh
wow we've been off since november 20.
great to be back i've been on a bit of a
news diet anything big happened
oh yeah
i tell you if the stuff that was
happening in america right now was
happening anywhere else in the world
we'd invade that country uh
biden did you see him today he announced
its inauguration
theme america united and all i could
think is
boy you have spent a lot of time in the
basement uh
there's
there's 20 000 armed troops
on heightened alert in washington right
now and joe
will be giving his inauguration speech
in front of basically nobody
uh welcome to my world joe
no these i just want to just want to say
you hear some people here these are we
are not allowed to have an audience
anymore i'm not complaining about that
we are very appreciative of the
authorities
on all levels who have let us be here in
our studio we get it there's a crisis
out here in california and in the
country
so these are just the normal ass kissers
i i hope they're asked kissers
who hang around the studio who are
allowed to hear
[Applause]
i really have no chance but but uh joe
outlined his plan today uh for the
future he wants to give every
american a check for fourteen hundred
dollars best grandpa
ever
but let's see what but let's let's
review what's happened while we were off
uh oh yeah there was an insurrection at
the capitol
a bunch of fox news freaks and q anon
nuts
from deep red districts bashed and
rammed and broke their way into the
capital
instead of getting there the usual way
by being elected
uh i mean you all saw the video right
they stormed in and they chased
retreating police up the stairs
ransacked the building this is something
i never thought
i would see in america trump supporters
taking the stairs
[Applause]
even the people who wrote it aren't
laughing that much so
that's where i have people help me help
me at home
but it was sad right to see this in
america people were hiding
under their desks in the capitol looking
for hidey holes
i mean so in the senate someone tried to
get into a closet
and and and lindsey graham said get out
of here this is my spot
i kid lindsey graham i don't even know
what that means
but democrats are now saying that they
witnessed the day before listen to this
day before the attack they witness
republican lawmakers
giving some of the rioters who came back
the next day
tours of the capitol this is the day
before
the attack giving tours
to the people who are coming to ransack
the next day this is the senate chamber
where we will be hanging mike pence and
we're walking and we're walking
okay so that happens and then let's see
what else happened oh yeah trump got
impeached again there's not a rerun
trump got impeached again for egging on
the
mob and this time 10 republicans isn't
this interesting
10 republicans voted for impeachment all
it took was for them to get
personally attacked by a violent mob
waving trump flags
the other 95 percent of republicans
still okay with that
more of a think joke i guess uh
[Music]
rough crowd on my payroll still a rough
crowd
that's what i'm dealing with okay
but listen it's 147 republican lawmakers
this is the senators and congressmen are
still standing by the lie
that the election was fraudulent after
the attack took place
after the attack and because of the
attack now congress put in
more metal detectors which republicans
are refusing to use
or sometimes just rushing right through
because that could violate their freedom
to overtake a legally elected government
by armed rebellion and who wants to live
in a country like that
so this is historic
this is historic for a president to be
impeached for a second time
for a second time trump has been asked
to leave office three if you count the
election
two two impeachments he's like he's like
the vaccine you need
you need two doses and still no
guarantees
but he's having a rough time in his last
five days in office trump he was uh
twitter threw him off he's been banned
on facebook instagram
youtube the pga golfing
the love of his life canceled his big
tournament new jersey
uh deutsche bank no longer be giving
loans to the trump family
everyone's turning their back on this
guy his bank in florida dumped him
uh in new york the the
he lost his contract for the ice skating
rink
and ivanka just wants to be friends it's
sad
the head of the mushroom trade
association asked today that bushroom
was no longer be compared to his dick
this is very very sad for any man
but amid all of this of course the biden
inauguration is going to happen and we
are going to have a new president
and uh he's being welcomed in with open
arms i don't know if you know marjorie
taylor green she's one of the new
republican congress people there
a q a on person she has drafted articles
of impeachment
against biden i'm not kidding she said
she says she's going to file
on january 21st his second day in office
well she wants to give him a chance
you